♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
DREW MICHAEL:
I have a hard time with people,
so, here we go.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Social media has changed
the way we think,
the way we process
our own language,
how we sound.
I remember in the '16 election,
they were talking about The Rock
maybe running for president.
I said that to a friend,
I was like,
"Yo, I heard The Rock
might run for president."
My buddy was like,
"Is The Rock a democrat?"
And I was like, "Dude,
listen to the sentence...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...that you just said."
"Is The Rock a democrat?"
I don't know,
he's a fake wrestling character.
I don't know where he stands
on healthcare.
"Is The Rock a democrat?"
I don't know,
did the yellow Power Ranger
support the war in Iraq?
What the fuck are we
talking about?
(LAUGHTER)
Where does Mickey Mouse
stand on abortion?
I don't know.
Is he a second trimester
or before kind of mouse?
Or more like a hardline...
(MIMICS MICKEY) "Life
begins at conception, folks!"